travelled me to some of the most
beautiful spots in cities around the
world
Rome's Spanish Steps the historic
neighborhoods of Paris and Shanghai the
rolling landscape of Central Park
the tight-knit blocks of Tokyo or Fez
the wildly sloping streets of the
favelas of Rio de Janeiro the dizzying
stepwells of Jaipur the arch pedestrian
bridges of Venice now let's go to some
newer cities six downtown's built across
six continents in the 20th century why
do none of these places have any of the
charming characteristics of our older
cities or let's go to six suburbs built
on six continents in the 20th century
why did none of them have any of the
lyrical qualities that we associate with
the places that we cherish the most now
maybe you think I'm just being nostalgic
why does it matter who cares if there is
this creeping sameness the setting our
planet well it matters because most
people around the world are gravitating
to urban areas globally and how we
design those urban areas could well
determine whether we thrive or not as a
species so we already know that people
who live in transit rich areas live in
apartment buildings have a far lower
carbon footprint than their suburban
counterparts so maybe one lesson from
that is if you love nature you shouldn't
live in it
but I think the dry statistics of what's
known as transit-oriented development
only tells part of the story because
cities if they're going to attract
people have to be great they have to be
powerful magnets with distinctive appeal
to bring in all those new green
urbanites and this is not just an
aesthetic issue mind you this is an
issue of international consequence
because today every day literally
hundreds of thousands of people are
moving into a city somewhere mainly in
the global south and when you think
about that ask yourself are they
condemned to live in the same bland
cities we built in the 20th century or
can we offer them something better and
to answer that question you have to
unpack how we got here in the first
place first mass production just like
consumer goods and chain stores we
mass-produce glass and steel and
concrete and asphalt and drywall and we
deploy them in mind-numbingly similar
ways across the planet second regulation
so take cars for instance cars travel at
very high speeds they're susceptible to
human error so when we're asked as
architects to design a new Street we
have to look at drawings like this that
tell us how high a curb needs to be that
pedestrians need to be over here and
vehicles over there a loading zone here
a drop-off there what the car really did
in the 20th century is it created this
carved-up segregated landscape or take
the latter firetruck you know those big
ladder trucks that are used to rescue
people from burning buildings those have
such a wide turning radius that we have
to deploy an enormous amount of pavement
of asphalt to accommodate them or take
the critically important wheel
here a wheelchair necessitates a
landscape of minimal slopes and
redundant vertical circulation so
wherever there's a stair there has to be
an elevator or a ramp now don't get me
wrong please I am all for pedestrian
safety firefighting and certainly
wheelchair access both of my parents
were in wheelchairs at the end of their
lives so I understand very much that
struggle but we also have to acknowledge
that all of these well intentioned rules
they had the tremendous unintended
consequence of making illegal the ways
in which we used to build cities
similarly illegal at the end of the 19th
century right after the elevator was
invented we built these charming urban
buildings these lovely buildings all
over the world from Italy to India and
they had maybe 10 or 12 apartments in
them they had one small elevator and a
staircase that wrapped them and a light
well and not only were they charming
buildings that were cost effective they
were communal you ran into your neighbor
on that stairwell well you can't build
this either by contrast today when we
have to build a major new apartment
building somewhere we have to build lots
and lots of elevators and lots of fire
stairs and we have to connect them with
these long anonymous dreary corridors
now developers when they're confronted
with the cost of all of that common
infrastructure they have to spread that
cost over more apartments so they want
to build bigger buildings what that
results in is the thud the dull thud of
the same apartment building being built
in every city across the world and this
is not only creating physical sameness
it's creating social sameness because
these buildings are more expensive to
build and it helped to create an
affordability crisis in cities all over
the world including places like
Vancouver now I said there was a third
reason for all this sameness and that's
really a psychological one
it's a fear of difference and architects
hear this all the time from their
clients if I try that new idea will I be
sued
will I be mocked better safe than sorry
and all of these things have conspired
together to blanket our planet with a
homogeneity that I think is deeply
problematic so how can we do the
opposite how can we go back to building
cities that are physically and
culturally varied again how can we build
cities of difference I would argue that
we should start by injecting into the
global the local this is already
happening with food for instance you
just look at the way in which craft beer
has taken on corporate beer or how many
of you still eat Wonder Bread I bet most
of you don't and I bet you don't because
you don't want processed food in your
life so if you don't want processed food
why would you want processed cities why
would you want these mass-produced
bleached places where all of us have to
live and work every day so technology
was a big part of the problem in the
twentieth century when we invented the
automobile what happened is the world
all bent towards the invention and we
recreated our landscape around it in the
21st century technology can be part of
the solution if it bends to the needs of
the world and so what do I mean by that
take the autonomous vehicle I don't
think the autonomous vehicle is exciting
because it's a driverless car that to me
only implies that there's even more
congestion on the roads frankly I think
what's exciting about the autonomous
vehicle is the promise and I want to
stress the word promise given the recent
accident in Arizona the promise that we
could have these small urban vehicles
that could safely commingle with
pedestrians and bicycles that would
enable us
to design humane streets again streets
without curbs may be streets like the
wooden walkways on Fire Island or maybe
we could design streets with the
cobblestone of the 21st century
something that captures kinetic energy
melts snow helps you with your fitness
when you walk or remember those big
ladder fire trucks what if we could
replace them and all the asphalt that
comes with them with drones and robots
that could rescue people from burning
buildings and if you think that's
outlandish you'd be amazed to know how
much of that technology is already being
used today in rescue activity but now
I'd like you to really imagine with me
imagine if we could design the
hovercraft wheelchair right an invention
that would not only allow equal access
but would enable us to build the Italian
hill town of the 21st century I think
you'd be amazed to know that if just a
few of these inventions responsive to
human need would completely transform
the way we could build our cities now I
bet you're also thinking we don't have
kinetic cobblestones or flying
wheelchairs yet so what can we do about
this problem with today's technology and
my inspiration for that question comes
from a very different city the city of
Ulaanbaatar Mongolia I have clients
there who've asked us to design a 21st
century open-air village that's
sustainably heated using today's
technology in the heart of their
downtown and that's to cope with their
frigid winters and the project is both
poetry and prose the poetry is really
about evoking the local the mountainous
terrain using colors to pick up the
spectacular light understanding how to
interpret the nomadic traditions that
animate the nation of Mongolia the prose
has been the development of a catalogue
of buildings of small buildings that are
fairly affordable
using local construction materials and
technology that can still provide new
forms of housing new workspace new shops
and cultural buildings like a theater a
museum even a haunted house while
working on this in our office we've
realized that we're building upon the
work of our colleagues including
architect Tatiana Bilbao working in
Mexico City Pritzker laureate Alejandro
Aravena working in Chile and recent
Pritzker winter Balakrishna Doshi
working in India and all of them are
building spectacular new forms of
affordable housing but they're also
building cities of difference because
they're building cities that respond to
local communities local climates and
local construction methods we're
doubling down on that idea we're
researching a new model for our growing
cities with gentrification pressures
that could build upon that late
nineteenth century model with that
Center core but a prototype that could
shape-shift in response to local needs
and local building materials all of
these ideas to me are nostalgia free
they all tell me that we can build
cities that can grow but grow in a way
that reflects the diverse residents that
live in those cities grow in a way that
can accommodate all income groups all
colors Creed's genders we could build
such spectacular cities that we could
disincentivize for all and actually
protect nature we can grow cities that
are high-tech but also respond to the
timeless cultural needs of the human
spirit I'm convinced that we can build
cities of difference that helped to
create the global mosaic to which so
many of us aspire thank you
[Applause]